Hi zusammen!
[Kiki] Das war cool, ne?
[Hamza] Ja, das war cool!
Also: Hi zusammen!
Wir machen heute Apfelkekse und zwar auf Türkisch: Elmali Kurabiye.
Ich persönlich kenne das nur aus dem türkischen Raum, diese Apfelkekse..
[Kiki] Hab ich Apfelkuchen oder Apfelkekse gesagt?
[Hamza] Kekse!
Also! Heute ganz, ganz mürbe und zarte Plätzchen, die gehen wirklich das ganze Jahr über!
Und meine Tante macht da immer so eine ganz besondere Form
und ich wollte sie euch einfach mal zeigen weil sie so wunderwunderschön ist und auch der Geschmack ist einmalig.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt direkt mal - also wir fangen direkt mal an!
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr wie immer hier unten in der Infobox.
So ich lege jetzt los mit meinen Äpfeln und da passen am besten säuerliche Äpfel.
Und die schäle ich jetzt erstmal und dann werde ich sie fein reiben.
Jetzt habe ich noch Zucker dazugegeben
und das Ganze wird jetzt in der Pfanne so lange geköchelt, bis diese Flüssigkeit hier - sieht man die gut?
[Kiki] Bis diese Flüssigkeit hier..
[Hamza] Ja, die sieht man gut!
[Kiki]Bis die komplett verdampft. Das dauert so ein paar Minuten..
[Hamza] Achso da! Nein, die sieht man nicht! *lacht*
Genau, also das ist alles Flüssigkeit aus den Äpfeln und das muss jetzt komplett verdampfen.
Und dann erst geben wir Zimt dazu und lassen das ein wenig auskühlen.
Ihr könnt auch gerne noch Nüsse zu den Äpfeln geben.
Das passt für mich perfekt zusammen, dann hat man noch so ein bisschen Crunch drin.
Was sehr gut passt sind z.B. Walnüsse oder Haselnüsse.
Ich hatte jetzt noch Haselnüsse aus Ordu da und dann hab ich die natürlich kleingehackt und nochmal da mit rein gegeben.
Und jetzt gebe ich die Füllung kurz an die Seite dass die ein bisschen abkühlen kann.
Und in der Zwischenzeit bereiten wir den Teig zu.
Ihr könnt dafür eure Küchenmaschine nehmen oder ihr nehmt ganz einfach die sauberen Hände, das funktioniert auch.
Und auch da schreibe ich euch natürlich alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben in die Infobox.
Ich gebe jetzt hier zuerst die zimmerwarme Butter in eine ausreichend große Schüssel.
Da kommt Puderzucker dazu, ich nehme jetzt keinen Kristallzucker.
Das ist nämlich ein Teig, der anders als bei deutschen Mürbeteigen nicht gekühlt wird.
Wir müssen den gleich direkt weiterverarbeiten.
Daher einmal mit Puderzucker verkneten und dann kommen auch schon alle anderen Zutaten mit dazu.
Ich habe jetzt noch Speisestärke, das Ei, den Joghurt und das Öl mit dazu gegeben.
Statt Joghurt (falls ihr den grad mal nicht da habt) könntet ihr auch Milch verwenden.
Und jetzt gebe ich auch noch Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Das ist zwar ein sehr leckerer, buttriger und mürber Teig
Aber da braucht man auf jeden Fall noch ein Geschmacksaroma.
Ich nehme da super super gerne Vanilleextrakt, geb das noch mit dazu.
Und ich bin ganz ehrlich: Normalerweise bei so einem Teig - weil das hat so ein komisches Handgefühl - hätte ich die Küchenmaschine benutzt
aber ich dachte ich mach's einfach so originalgetreu mit den Händen.
[Hamza] Richtig traditionell!
[Kiki] So traditionell, genau!
Und jetzt gebe ich noch Mehl dazu. Achtung, jetzt müsst ihr aufpassen!
Also ich hab hier mein Mehl zwar abgemessen aber es kommt immer auch auf die Größe des Eis an
deswegen lasse ich einen Teil davon weg und gebe das gleich mit dazu und jubel hier aber auch schon Backpulver mit unter.
So, und dann nach Gefühl immer ein bisschen mehr Mehl dazugeben.
So der Teig ist innerhalb 2-3min zusammengeknetet.
Der sollte nicht mehr kleben, also schon relativ fest sein aber auch nicht zu trocken.
Und jetzt gebe ich mir ein bisschen Mehl auf die Arbeitsfläche
und dann wird der so relativ quadratisch ausgerollt.
Nachdem ihr den Teig dann ca. 3mm dünn ausgerollt habt, einfach in Quadrate schneiden.
Ich habe jetzt hier 8x8cm genommen. Ihr müsst das nicht so genau nehmen
aber wir müssen schon relativ große Quadrate haben weil das Muster verbraucht auch ein bisschen Platz.
So und jetzt geht's hier ans Muster. Das zeige ich euch hier am besten.
Ich hab mir jetzt ein Quadrat hier weggenommen und jetzt nehme ich mir meinen Pizzaroller
und schneide erstmal bis zur Hälfte ein.
Das muss ich zeigen, erklären ist immer ein bisschen schwierig!
Bis zur Hälfte. Und jetzt nehmt ihr schräg gegenüber nochmal die Seite und schneidet dann genauso oft ein.
So, als nächstes schnappt ihr euch diese Seite.
Also merkt euch einfach: Das ist die Seite, wo die Striche reingehen und nicht die schöne quadratische Seite.
Da gebt ihr jetzt einen halben Teelöffel von der Füllung rein,
klappt die Seite, die schräg gegenüber ist, einmal um...
so ist das Ganze dann safe und kann nicht auslaufen.
So, schön verschließen..
Und jetzt immer abwechselnd die Streifen übereinander klappen.
So, jetzt muss der Ofen vorgeheizt sein auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
und dann werden die Kekse für ca. 18min gebacken.
Sie dürfen nicht ganz so dunkel sein sondern müssen wirklich so ganz zart und ganz ganz hell goldbraun sein.
Und nach dem Backen lasse ich die Kekse dann auskühlen und gebe schön Puderzucker obendrauf.
[Kiki] So! Jetzt machen wir den Taste Test, sind rüber gewandert ins Wohnzimmer
[Kiki] aber irgendwie... da fehlt noch jemand!
[Kiki] Moment!
[Kiki] Oh, ein Hamza!
[Hamza] Ich bin da! So!
Schön meinen Bauch abdecken weil ich hab ein paar Kilo zu viel!
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall! Nein, Spaß!
[Kiki] Du hast grad noch ein Stück Kuchen verdrückt!
[Hamza] Genau, deswegen fühle ich mich grad schlecht. Aber...das sind Kekse!
[Kiki] Kekse gehen immer!
[Hamza] Kekse gehen immer!
[Kiki] Also, das sind Apfelkekse. Sehr, sehr zart, sehr mürbe..
[Hamza] Ich hab noch nie türkische Apfelkekse gegessen. Also auf türkische Art und Weise, noch nie!
[Kiki] Ja, hab ich auch noch nie gemacht! Also für YouTube zumindest.
[Kiki] So, dann..Hamza probier mal!
[Hamza] Soll ich probieren?
[Hamza] Die sind schon recht groß, ne? Für Kekse?
[Kiki] Ja, finde ich auch!
[Kiki] Kleiner gingen sie aber nicht wegen des Musters.
[Hamza] Wegen der Form. Ja, das merkt man.
[Hamza] Sieht aber schön aus, sieht schick aus! Sieht ein bisschen aus wie dieser American Apple Pie, kann das sein?
[Kiki] Ja, die haben auch so ein Gittermuster, das stimmt!
[Hamza] Die haben dieses Gittermuster drauf, ne?
[Hamza] Mmmh!
[Kiki] Ich glaub du musst größer abbeißen damit du von der Füllung was abbekommst!
[Kiki] Sieht man schon die Füllung? Komm mal näher ran!
[Kiki] Aaaah!
[Hamza] Sehr mürbe!
Kekse sehr mürbe, also sehr lecker! So, jetzt kommt die Füllung.
[Kiki] Das ist ganz normal!
[Hamza] Mürbe halt!
[Kiki] Ja, ist halt sehr mürbe auch durch die Speisestärke!
[Hamza] Mhm! Ist da auch Zimt drin?
[Kiki] Jaa! Hast du nicht aufgepasst beim Videodreh?
[Hamza] Keine Ahnung, ich hab's vergessen jetzt!
[Kiki] Aber Hamza ist wirklich so! Wir drehen was und er dreht und merkt gar nicht, was sich hinter der Kamera abspielt!
[Hamza] Ich find das hat was! Also ist mal was anderes so 'ne Füllung!
[Hamza] Kann man gut mit Tee trinken, ja?
[Kiki] Jaa! Schwarztee passt perfekt oder ein Kaffee oder ein ganz anderer Tee mit Früchten..
[Hamza] Und von der Größe auch heftig!
[Kiki] Findest du sie zu groß? Sei ehrlich!
Was heißt zu groß? Wenn sie kleiner wären, würde ich davon auch 2-3 Stück essen. Von daher kommt es auf die gleiche Größe am Ende an.
[Hamza] Aber das kann man schon mit 'nem Stück Kuchen vergleichen!
[Kiki] So ein halbes Stück, ne?
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall von der Größe her. Also ist schon sehr, sehr lecker.
Sehr mürbe wie gesagt der Teig. Apfel, Zimt schmeckt man raus. Schmeckt gut!
[Kiki] Schmeckst du die Nüsse oder sind da zu wenig Nüsse?
[Hamza] Ein bisschen zu wenig glaube ich!
[Kiki] Das ist echt was für Besuch, ne? Wenn Besuch kommt, dann tischt man diese wundervollen Kekse auf!
[Hamza] Also von der Optik her mega!
[Kiki] Optisch wunderwunderschön!
[Kiki] Ich beiß mal rein! Mmmh!
[Hamza] Mürbe, ne?
[Kiki] Boah! Ihr könnt natürlich jetzt diese extrem zarten Kekse - die haben sich grad richtig im Mund verteilt!
[Hamza] Merkst du, ne?
[Kiki] Voll!
[Kiki] Die kann man jetzt auch einpacken und verschenken!
[Hamza] ..und verschenken!
[Kiki] Es gibt keine schönere Wertschätzung wenn man sieht, wie viel Fingerarbeit das ist!
[Hamza] ..wie viel Arbeit das ist, ja!
[Kiki] Hast du auch gemerkt, ne? Hamza ist zwischenzeitlich weggegangen und ich war in der Küche und hab die ganze Zeit weitergemacht.
[Hamza] Ja, aber man merkt das auch. Von der Optik sieht man auch, wie viel Arbeit da drin steckt auf jeden Fall.
[Kiki] Und extrem zart! Ich glaub das sind die zartesten Plätzchen, die ich je gegessen habe. Also heftig!
[Kiki] Also macht's unbedingt nach und hinterlasst dem Video ein Däumchen nach oben! Und was noch?
[Hamza] Guckt mir beim essen zu!
[Kiki] Oha du bist schon manchmal gemein!
[Kiki] Hinterlasst uns ein kostenloses Abo und dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Rezept!
[Kiki] Tschüss, eure Kiki!
[Hamza] *hohes Summen*
[Kiki] Und der Hamza!